when a normal stress ball was placed  into the clockworks on fine the result  was a stress ball that at random  intervals between a minute and five  minutes in length hurled itself at the  face of the person in closest proximity  to it if the face is covered or  otherwise protected it will  alternatively aim for the stomach or  crotch objects secured and destroyed  however on very fine it became a  palm-sized teddy bear stuffed with  plastic beads the object is animate and  seems to have a fascination with  cuddling nuzzling ankles and  infrequently requests signs of affection  object contained for further study one  doctor noted and whoever decides to look  into this further be nice to the little  guy alright